venu son tournage du déménagement
[Musique]
viens juste montrer déjà parce que le
décor c'est un faux déménagement bien
évidemment les cartons extrêmement léger
c'est lourd le canapé par contre il est
vraiment très lourd ça fait à peu près
une heure et demie comporte ce canapé
j'aurais dû appeler le court métrage
mais qu'il se rend compte avec latin
mézières de déménageur on va devoir
porter un prix donc extrêmement long
quelle est l'histoire du déménagement
deux personnages qui a suite d'un bug ne
se connaissent pas mais pourtant ils
vont perdre un déménagement ensemble
nous avons le personnage de yacine qui
plutôt rangé dans sa vie professionnelle
le genre de gars qui est tellement sage
qu'il ose pas dire non à son boss
d'accord ok là on tourne la scène
d'introduction qu'on voit la soumission
de yacine envers le bot les patrons tout
le monde a toujours détesté d'avoir
c'est assez jouissif de jouer ça nous
avons le personnage ensuite de max le
jacquard qui lui a réussi un petit peu à
se lancer mais la réalité c'est que ben
il a plus de tués dans un échange
d'étudiants
c'est tout petit ça me rappelle moi
vachement lait début quand j'ai vraiment
arrêter de travailler que j'ai fait que
des vidéos sur internet parce que ça va
marcher
est-ce que ça va durer ce qui est
intéressant dans le film c'est que tu te
rends jamais ne tranche pas la question
ces deux personnages qui ont besoin d'un
peu de l'un et de l'autre pour se
motiver
sans tout remettre en question c'est la
séquence émotion ce petit comédien qui
mesure 1 m 80 go est quand même celle ci
émane bâtisse en forme le duo de ce
court métrage je suis depuis longtemps
fait débat audiovisuel sur internet mais
était beaucoup trop grand je me le dire
devant la caméra doit être comme je sais
jouer les jambes écartées ça règle le
problème
mais mettez pas sans arrêt à jiss on
fait la fiche afghane tout est possible
tu crois pas mais il pleut ça ne
fonctionne pas la plus grosse variable
c'est la météo qu'on soit avec spielberg
aussi friands
on est quand même tributaire
nuage va là on va attendre c'est là où
il ya plus de bruit plus du mouvement
les cuisses de voitures dans les
conditions parfaites pour tourner
moi je suis là qu on t'arrête tout ça
nous met dans la boîte
[Musique]
cette vidéo est dédicacé à tous les
jeunes qui croient qu'on s'amuse sur un
tournage de cyprien face à moi il fait
du temps même jour à la première fois à
une réunion salle 8
[Musique]
bref mais une petite souris qui se passe
à la fin du jeu dans le nouvel
appartement de max et du coup on a des
chips rapport à manger parce que sinon
c'est pas d'accord c'est à dire c'est
qu'en fait le personnage de maximy en
ligne font de moi c'est important est ce
qui est bien c'est qu'on voit que ses
nouveaux amis perso je vais y aller on
comprend dans baptista gardé contact
plus qu'un clic et je vais sur youporn
[Musique]
fait très froid
on a des trous comme ça dans les jambes
c'est chiant bonne idée
ayant quitté le roumain merci
amélioration c'est la fin du tournage du
déménagement et j'en ai très très longue
ouais c'était vachement bien c'était
vraiment chouette l'équipe était mortel
jeu très content moi de collaborer avec
les parasites qui ont réalisé du coup ce
court métrage leurs appareils du script
ça leur a plu à la recherche du parasite
c'est un modèle aux assistants sur sur
ce petit corps est rageant nous avons un
deuxième modèle c'est un parasite
réalisateur on retrouve en est très
content non et voilà c'est un paradis de
type comédien je viens d'incruster un
des personnages des parasites dans le
film conçu prix on vous invite à aller
regarder symptômes d'amour merci à slim
qui a incarné dupouy dessine je suis
très content d'avoir partagé ça avec lui
merci fanta d'avoir sponsoriser ce
making of merci à vous de l'avoir
regardé espère que le court métrage vous
a plu n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
vert comme disent tous les youtube
heures dans un pousse bleus voila voila
et guillaume qui me fout la honte
aboa très vite youtube
[Musique]